hey guys how's it goin still guess where
we are out right now I'm in Culver City
and I'm so excited because this is going
to be the newest Dunkin Donuts and they
open next Tuesday but they're doing a
little preview event or here
guess who's already here is calling wait
wait wait
should I go on - you did but I did maybe
mine's at the other side this is great
I'm so excited we're also having a
little Mario Kart party later so we're
gonna get some donuts party I know
you're very excited
you're calling
it's for sale let's buy it it's an
investment the dog of the car car oh I'm
sorry with a dog a dog on top of us with
it we now on our way it's do a little
shopping we're going on an adventure
this week and I'm super excited about it
we're gonna go on some fun hikes in Utah
we're gonna get a couple at some hiking
gear because I'm not fully prepared for
actual hiking you know yeah there any a
fanny pack
I need a fanny pack that's like bigger
but I'm not sure if I should get a
backpack or not like one of the smaller
ones so they need to have like shoes
because we're gonna be hiking through a
river
we have donuts in the backseat windows
up that's waving windows are up cuz it's
warm hot outside
real hot oh my every time we come into
this parking lot like people drive me
nuts when they're parking I might have
had this discussion with you guys
previously but I like to let everybody
know how many parking spots there is you
lock me let me help you be hey let me
out Oh Jenna let me have to be let me
out never door yeah I will turn this car
amazing look 53 spaces 53 spaces I gotta
let everyone know lock the windows okay
open the car okay I push you out you
behave okay behave I'm behaving if you
don't behave you and be living hands
from Lulu no no peanuts Japan oh you'll
get your DJ set
there's 53 spaces this actually said
full but I'm gonna help 53 lying I
thought that I got the shirt up the
lobster and I'm really upset to find out
that it's true
it's a crawfish gray free fish I want is
a crawfish crawfish is how great you
think it's a crayfish wait we go up here
you can work with that found this really
super cute turtles like I love it love
it look how cute this is Oh a little
dirt on it
how much is it Jen tell us tell us it
was originally 165 you're crazy
actual insanity story of my life cute
don't need any more what Sharp's back
gotta you cute little items I'm so
excited because this pair of jeans I was
like I will never pay full price for you
and they were on sale oh I mean they
have paint splattered all over them so
basically I probably could have done
that to my my own case but I was wrong
so many hug I want cute puppies i buy
tell anyone my dog's name is spinner
Kevin is probably right now we're gonna
go to hot topic because we have been
really into hacky sacking lately and I'd
like to bring Zach back I'm bringing sac
back what you other suckers don't know
how to act
almost everything good yourself oh I
won't get 150 right deal oh look at this
backpack I don't need it I don't need
the backpack I don't need the backpack
clock look it walk away walk away find a
hacky problems it's really light know
that's the problem
alright we got a couple things that Lulu
for our hiking adventures and I learned
something today
so this is one of the biggest and 11
stores that has the men's clothing and
they have the men's bag can I show them
this
this is shorter a little learns bag just
need to be like a briefcase for a man
right why did they give it to you
because I said I wanted oh okay what's
our next destination Jen um I don't know
Apple store maybe are we going do we
need to mix it up link so a leather
backpack right I have a backpack we're
set probably not I mean I can we can
switch to like I'll carry the backpack -
yeah okay so that's with the shrimp
would you look at the shrimp now you
looked up profit okay become shrimp
because I think this is a shrimp you
know it's not a shrimp
really okay but does it it's a shrimp it
is definitely a shrimp
it's not a master because those shrimps
are cooked da silly goose I once had
shrimps delivered to my table and the
eyes were still on them and I haven't
had a shrimp sink
actually when I went to Bora Bora so
that was like four years ago four years
ago yes it was three years yeah huh yeah
the sack
oh why I catch I feel like yeah he's
what feed you did you spin in dime you
would definitely be like that okay hold
on I'm gonna go through this the circle
now on the sack circle
pppp pppp pppp great song so our little
party's underway we're a hacky sack in
and rolling in my DJ set I don't know
how to work it so I literally do not
know how to work this thing and I don't
think there's a pin that I can pull to
make York looks good though it does look
good it looks but the problem is I need
one of the audio cables and I don't have
one and I have to get one of the Sonos
bridges to be able to connect I don't I
know what I have to do and I can't
explain it because it's too much am i
what my brain is not working today I
would took a nap and I woke up and I was
really confused so where I was and
what's going on
where's Matt Matt mother Matt is not
coming wait yep Matt my number one Sammy
is coming okay we like
belly hurts I need to make sugar snacks
today so ed let's talk about these chips
they're homemade yeah yeah I mean the my
home today made these like an hour old
hour old
so we're gonna do a taste test when Matt
gets here to see Matt can figure out
where they came from if he likes them
and we're not gonna tell him it I've
made them we're gonna say that there's
free chips we got them and we just think
that you should try it or whatever
something like that something like that
and then I'll stand behind him where he
gives his honest opinion these free
chips are terrible put or well these are
really good and then I will react or cry
hopefully he doesn't realize that there
that's my handwriting or something I
don't think he's gonna be like listen
swatching edge right Cayenne wrong four
times already and he wrote it wrong
again
good cayenne palm where's max I am here
come the chips you a salsa no I want you
guys to Ethan ship we're gonna eat the
chest anybody talk about them right here
the thing about the chips is that we
will be fine until I'm just gonna go
you're having that meeting the ones that
we know it's just that's sapote late
chip oh my mole
freaky dope on three all three
- you got to share all that one that
doesn't want back I don't want chips
oh I see this is war from attrition from
Google come on have one - hissing dude
yeah beautiful bra ugly levels I just
put them on my fingers are you
it is a communal I like that this is
probably like on every level
why just my dad Walkman come on
comfortable feel like you yeah they
taste better when I get my news what do
you think I'm indifferent about the
chips
chicken scratch oh my god no let's go
there's isn't there oh I'm gonna stop
recording oh god I was so good oh hi so
I didn't realize it it on my blog but
yeah so we're off to Utah gonna be doing
a fun hike and I'm really excited
so until then uh I guess I'll see you
guys later as we watching that ship
challenge and I was like dying I'm just
finishing editing it oh my god everyone
thought it was so funny when I laugh too
hard I actually start to cry so that's
that's what happened anyway I'll see you
guys tomorrow
happy Veda video every day August I'm
tired I just will be sure that my tat
it's probably sweaty here this is
probably sweaty so you should be
careless my baby you like it gonna get a
little